Simon the president he did a pretty good
job there but is that one you would
advise others to emulate well I mean
he's amazing the thing is when leaders
are heckled it's like the mass comes
down and you get a moment of truth this
is when the real person emerges and if
you're a great leader like I think
Barack Obama is you're basically a good
person I think this is an opportunity
for you to show that kind of strength if
someone's up there and they're putting
up an axe they were a little bit too
phony and it comes down and this sort of
thing happens then it is excruciating
and I thought Barack Obama handled that
absolutely perfectly and it will do him
no harm at all and what it was was it
was just his air of complete confidence
the mass didn't come down with him it
wasn't just what he said it was his
expression when he said it yes
absolutely because this is the real
person so there's there's no big leap
going on there between the real Barack
Obama in the Barack Obama who's up on
the stage this gives people an
opportunity to actually see the real
person who hears the kind of person that
you would find in the Oval Office
discuss in national security matters
having foreign policy meetings this is
exactly what people need from their
leaders they need to be able to know
that they can trust them that they're
confident they don't get scared in these
situations and they can control a
meeting anything less than that would
have had people worried it's used humor
though didn't get it didn't get angry
because you did use him he waited till
the boat's been taken out of the room by
the Secret Service before he did it lead
the juicier in the end I mean I think it
would help most people in there dealing
with tech as if they had the Secret
Service so what was your favorite sort
of tip fit in with a heckler again if
you have the Secret Service on your side
use them if not engaged then try and
make a moment Abbott noise it makes my
brave I supposed to try heckling in
those circumstances and I think so I
mean I think don't think the irony of
the situation would have been lost on
the man who was shouting no more
deportations as he was forcibly taken
somewhere against his will as an old
Peter Sellers one were one of my
favorites which is someone heckling a
Tory MP of the banksters what about the
workers which is as a Dean so what about
the workers what's your favorite foot
well I was thinking about the old Monty
Python like you know what Romans ever
done for us aqueducts you remember that
bad guys
so that was it yeah those one I remember
was a bit of Manning years ago I
slightly paraphrase it someone in the
audience said you fat [ __ ] and he went
get it right you you fat rich [ __ ] I
like wait Harry Harry Hill deals with
hecklers in the he totally disarms them
by saying well you might think that but
I know I've got a chicken at home in the
oven at home now I don't care that it's
just he takes what they're doing it's
really raises it takes what they want
out the situation right and moves it to
something he wants to say which is just
discussing his food at home well you do
a lot of business peaches and things
like that i did and people public
speaking doesn't necessarily come
naturally to a lot of business but as it
does to politicians and I Spit they're
pretty terrified of hecklers oh yeah
they are but I think you go back to the
question of why do people actually
heckle well it's because their voice
isn't being heard or they perceive their
voices not being heard within that room
and so as a speechwriter went on writing
speeches for people I'm always trying to
imagine what the people who are thinking
about a heckler I thiet thinking about
eglin are actually got going through
their mind and then you try and answer
that question because the speech is a
really weird thing it breaks all of the
rules of normal social interaction
normal social interaction is a dialogue
isn't it in a speech as a monologue and
to get away from it feeling really odd
and weird a good speech has the illusion
of a dialogue in which of course Obama
has always done so brilliantly with his
call and response thing and yes we can
that kind of preacher II engagement with
the audience of Barack Obama it's quite
easy because he's always come across a
very cool witty guy I mean is it
something you can learn dealing with a
heckler yeah I think one at one at one
of the mistakes that you can make and
it's a split-second judgment is whether
or not you're going to fight them or you
know it's kind of whether or not you you
engage with them or you try and
eliminate them I saw my comedy quite a
lot of his monologues people telling so
a bit but but actually goodies depend on
interruptions to a certain extent yes I
think you said Lee learned to love them
i think when everyone starts out there a
little worried by getting thrown off by
someone shouting something and there are
two kinds of it when you started out
there are people who are just telling
you you're not very good
which is more difficult to deal with
them people trying to me I mean you've
done stuff for have I got news for you
and I remember one of the producers
there say to me the worst thing is when
a comedian goes into a routine yes when
someone starts just doing material off
the back of something it's really when
you find as as was said that there are
moments of truth when someone heckles
when you find something new and
unexpected and real that's what people
enjoy watching another good heck or
because if someone comes and they say
something stupid but the comedians are
saying witty back that's that's really
great and if the hecklers with you
that's really good too we're not so good
for the comedian there well it can be I
mean they learn to turn to your
advantage you learn after a while that
you know you're going to get back to
what you want to say you're going to
take a little timeout deal with this
possibly find something you've never
found before a moment that will only be
seen by these people will be something
special and unique to that night and
then you get to go back to what you were
saying before